[Music]  if you want address for business with a  capital B or if you constantly mistaken  for the office in turn why not try  three-piece it's not just for weddings  you know and that's a bit of gravitas  gives you a lot more options to you can  leave your jacket open when you're  standing up like when you give a  presentation even look put together when  you take your jacket off to looks the  waistcoat the same color and pattern as  your suit safe sleek and serious option  two different color and pattern  [Music]  dangerous territory but if you pull it  off can be a great look the few tips  always leave the bottom button  unfastened also your tie can be a bit  louder because very little of it is  visible and don't overdo it with the  accessories tie pocket square that's it  and no belt with a three piece and one  more word of warning you may experience  a Winston Churchill moment like this  strong urge to wear a pocket watch on a  chain or smoke a cigar resist it  [Music]